let's say we have a gentleman who's a
handyman okay he fixes broken homes he
kind of is transient a little bit he's
not homeless but he he travels around
how would we develop this this character
his life's a mess but he kind of fixes
everybody else's life how would we make
him interesting by setting aside time to
invent just like and we took medicine
earlier Addison invented the light bulb
you have to invent the stuff that he
does and says you have to invent the
situations he's a handyman never really
had a really steady job he goes to one
particular house and that maybe he's
having trouble getting getting work and
he goes to one particular job and
there's a woman there who tries to
seduce him and so on I what I just said
I don't mean to suggest that that's
genius out of out of Shakespeare but it
is events and anecdotes and I'm
inventing the one of the best movies
ever made is is doubled indemnity and
when I was just describing sort of sound
emanating I mean first of all it how'd
you like to make a movie about an
insurance salesman that's not gonna
excite a lot of people here that's what
double indemnity is about so it's the
stuff that they do and as you remember
if you if you're seeing the movie if
you're having you gotta see it it's just
a one of the great great great films
he's going out to the to try to sell an
insurance policy at one of those
mansions in my neighborhood Los Feliz
Silver Lake Los Feliz he says it's one
of those thirty-five thousand dollar
mansions I mean you know this is 90 48
or whatever it is I mean 30 it's not
even a fraction of the Commission for
the realtor you know these days and then
he meets this woman there and it's so
strange what she's doing and that she's
very seductive just like we were
describing about our handyman but the
point is it's the action it's what it's
the actions that characters take that
define their character there's a
wonderful book very underappreciated by
a writer who died a few years ago
it's called plots and characters and by
the way plots is first not by accident
and also in Aristotle's Poetics the
first book on dramatic writing he
clearly says plot is what's really
important not character because again
character flows out of plot there isn't
any character outside of a plot and if
there's a plot as automatically
characters that are that are going to be
in it so once again I just can't hammer
enough on how amateurs fill the thoughts
don't get that that it's really about
story and that what you the real work of
a writer is inventing the actions
milord cowman is the name of the writer
who wrote the book plots and characters
and he has one of the most timeless
brilliant lines in it that I've ever
heard and here is I've already said it
which is that it is action that defines
character and not the other way around
I'm gonna say it again it's action that
defines character and not the other way
around people who think it's the other
way around are the kind of people who
are doing these character workshops will
invent this a character who has all
these traits and qualities and
characteristics and then will turn her
loose and see what she does know define
what she does tell us what does she do
and that'll tell us who she is that's
true in your dramatic narrative that you
write for the screen it's also true in
your life isn't it I mean I like to
think that I'm a moral principled
reliable decent person but I look back
at what I've done in my life and I see
shortchanging myself and others
disappointing myself and others
constantly frequently acting out of fear
I would say my actions define me is a
little bit of a coward I'm easily I'm
afraid of a lot of things
it's not the way I want to be but again
it's what I do it's the actions the
events the incidents the anecdotes in my
life that tell me who I am and that tell
anybody who who they are and that tell
audiences in movies in movie theaters
looking at the screen that's what tells
them who those characters are Tony
Soprano is a function of what he does
he's a vicious murderer criminal he's
also a father and a husband he's also a
troubled man who's having blackouts
fainting spells and these he's worried
he has so worried that he does a really
worse wimpish thing which is engages a
psychiatrist you know a therapist a
woman on top of that I mean a mobster a
made man and the mob doesn't do that and
all of those things define for us who
who who he is again it's not like we've
defined the character and then put them
into the situation's we put in the
situations and then the situation's
define the character
you